hey guys bandit here well we made it
it's the end of 2021 2022 is literally
tomorrow and for the majority of you
watching this it's probably 2022 right
now
unless something happens after i stop
filming this and
all of us die before we get to enter
into 2022.
but if that doesn't happen then it's
probably 2022 right now happy new year
the end of 2021 also marks the end of
zelda's 35th anniversary and
damn it somebody's got to celebrate it
so here on the literal last day of 2021
i'm going to take this final chance to
make my official legend of zelda video
game tier list this is not a new concept
it's been done many times before my many
other creators across youtube but as we
say here on mass nintendo bandit frick
it we're gonna do it anyway i haven't
ever let my audience know publicly where
exactly i stand with each game in the
franchise so why not do it now one thing
that you'll notice off the bat is that
this tier list starts at s and only goes
up from there because all zelda games
are asked here well all canon zelda
games that is but let's use the sales
numbers of the games as the order that
we'll be talking about them for the list
starting from the lowest and ending with
the highest the worst selling zelda game
of all time and the first one on this
list is four swords adventures which is
right right here four swords adventures
which i've played but never completed
it's got a multiplayer gimmick which a
surprising amount of zelda fans really
really want to experience with mainline
games but it's also completely single
player friendly unlike its predecessor
which we will get to later on in this
list four swords adventures i feel is a
solid ss tier entry because it fixed
some frustrations with the first game
while still being a bonafide zelda game
full of puzzles and cool stuff next up
is the minish cap which i have played
but again have never completed i don't
know what it is with me and the handheld
zelda games maybe i have a problem
anyway the minish cap is a beautiful
game that handles 3d concepts in a 2d
zelda game very well the gameplay is
solid and the story is probably one of
the most unique in the entire series
what with the tiny people and the light
force and everything like that this one
goes in the triple s tier for being
triple amazing next up is the original
four swords now i've tried to play four
swords i really have especially when i
was a kid but i never could because with
this game you have to have four people
with four different game boy consoles in
order to even start the game i never had
that growing up and by the time that the
anniversary edition released for
purchase in 2011 which did have a single
player mode i was already past all these
games from my childhood and was playing
skyward sword and stuff like that which
is a much better game i assume anyway
because it literally locked me out from
playing it for the majority of my life
this is going to be our first s s-tier
entry okay it's a zelda game
and that's about it next up we have the
oracle games which have their sales
numbers looped together on the websites
that i was looking it up on so i'm also
going to place them together also
because i haven't played both of them i
have played seasons i believe and i
actually have the manga actually hold up
i have the manga give me a second
sorry about that i didn't lie i do have
the manga right here which you do have
to read from
you know like a manga so i'm decently
familiar with the games even though i
haven't played either of them to
completion they're fun and they check
all the boxes for what a zelda game
should be but definitely throw some
wrenches in the system as far as what
zelda lore usually looks like like how
it doesn't take place in the land of
hyrule but yet twin rova is behind all
the events of the game and there's the
master sword which is the master sword
but yet isn't the master sword at the
same time and other weird things like
that anyway it's kind of confusing so
this is going to be double s tier for
being a great solid zelda experience
that comes in two separate games now on
to zelda 2 the adventure of link this is
notoriously the most difficult zelda
game of all due to its
unique choices in gameplay it took the
overworld concept of the original game
and added in some side scroller
platforming action like a mario game
with a sword and it was just kind of
messy feeling but cool final boss fight
though anyway s tier for the second game
in the franchise good effort next up is
phantom hourglass and i have completed
this one as the direct sequel to the
wind waker i had some pretty high
expectations for this game even though
it was a handheld and unfortunately for
this game it didn't really meet any of
them but mostly the gameplay i didn't
like moving link with the touchpad i
didn't like swinging the sword with the
touchpad i didn't like jump attacking
with the touchpad the touchpad really
bothered me okay like i said though i
did finish this game and it was nice
s tier levels of nice
next up is the one the only the where is
it the original legend of zelda the one
that started it all there are some
obvious things we have to get out of the
way right off the bat as is true of any
older game especially these days now
that there are so many video games out
there of course it doesn't hold up to
modern standards of gameplay how the
top-down gameplay of the recent links
awakening release on the switch feels
night and day better than the original
game here but there is a larger much
more impactful detail to keep in mind
when judging a video game's value and
that is this little word that i like to
call legacy the legend of zelda is a
legend in entertainment as a whole
across video games and movies it
invented save states it invented
adventure as we know it pretty much the
legend of zelda should be placed in the
maximum sss
tier but because it does have some of
that aged gameplay going on there it's
gonna slide down to the sss tier as our
first game to be placed there next up is
the wind waker and just in case you were
wondering i am looping in all sales of
the games that had multiple releases
like the wind waker it's just easier
than talking about the games as if
they're separate games separately for
each release anyway wind waker is in my
opinion
one of the greatest games of all time
from the moment that gripping music that
sounds like rolling waves hits you when
you set sail on the open sea you know
you're in for an adventure like you've
never experienced before the way the
game handled different islands that you
could sail to if you wanted to or not
sail to if you didn't want to made it
feel like probably a lot bigger than it
was but even so the impact was still
there and always will be and with the hd
release it even fixed some of the few
problems i had with the game such as
having to do the song thing to reset the
wind every two seconds or having to take
a week's worth of gameplay just to find
all those little triforce pieces
scattered across the sea so honestly
quadruple ester no doubt about it one of
the only games i will always recommend
to everybody to play no matter your
history or what you're normally into
next up the infamously debatable skyward
sword there are people who absolutely
hate this game and there are people who
absolutely love this game the people who
hate this game normally focus on you
know
game play and the people who love it
normally focus on stuff like this
me personally i'm kind of down the
middle love the story yeah the gameplay
has some ideas that were mixed in there
that you're kind of like okay what were
you doing there nintendo but ultimately
the switch version fixed a lot of that
with the handheld modes so
yeah triple s tier great game good
experience awesome music next up we have
once again one of the most influential
zeldas of all time the legend of zelda a
link to the past now if you were to play
this game without playing it before
these days you would think it's just a
regular
top-down modern adventure game with a
big enough map and just enough puzzles
and adventures and dungeons but then you
realize this was the third zelda game
ever made and it originally released in
1991 just four years after zelda ii and
it still looks and feels like a modern
adventure 2d side-scrolling game and
then you understand that even among
zelda games a link to the past is a
giant plus it introduced tropes in
mechanics that are still used in games
to this day and that dark world music is
a real banger
sss tier for the timeless legend number
next is majora's mask now this game is
really something sp dang it now this
game is really something special in that
it's probably one of if not the darkest
video game ever created
so that's cool besides its strange
fixation on death it has a really neat
time resetting mechanic that only the
bravest games dare emulate these days
and it had the advantage of building off
of and improving upon its monumentally
successful predecessor which we will get
to later on in the list my only problem
with the game currently is that it's a
bit short solid triple s tier phenomenal
game not sure what part of it has
anything to do with zelda
though that's an original joke right
there up next we have twilight princess
how can i not find this in the okay
there we go the zelda game's so dark so
edgy and so mature that it was rated t
for teenagers and up
and
damn it i love it to death again some
people absolutely hate this game though
but you know that's the cool thing about
that was a loud motorcycle anyway that's
the cool thing about opinions you can
have yours i can have mine and we can
just exist together anyway i loved
everything about this game the art style
the music the gameplay lynx design his
voice the bosses ganondorf it all came
together in a beautiful
harmonic way and seriously i'm always
down to play this game welcome to the
tier of the giants twilight princess sss
tier we're getting pretty close to
finishing up now next up is lynx
awakening which if you combine the
original the dx and the switch releases
numbers at over 11 million sales
i don't know if i said that right but
you get the idea that makes it the best
selling 2d zelda game of all time which
it is pretty deserving of especially
since the recent switch release
introduced the world to the chibi clay
zelda which is something nobody knew we
wanted the game is again a solid zelda
title that checks all the boxes and
randomly features some mario enemies
just scattered around the world but
nothing too out of the ordinary as far
as gameplay is concerned plus it is
extremely short as opposed to all the
other zelda games with noobs being able
to complete the game in under 15 hours
on average and zelda elites finishing
the game in under 10 on average for
link's awakening verily it'd be the
nature of the game to go into double s
tier the next game on this list is the
super overrated ocarina of time that
nobody can forget about because it's so
dumb and overrated i mean why can't
people get over it already right
s s s s
s
tier because it's my list okay and i can
do what i want with it i love
everything about this game everything
and i know there are already people
hitting up the comment section saying i
just ruined the whole list and i'm too
clouded by my nostalgia and you know
what they're probably right i'm not too
prideful to admit that there is probably
quite a bit of nostalgia that goes into
my placement of ocarina of time on this
tier list but hear me out as far as
legacy is concerned you have to admit
ocarina of time was to 3d adventure
games as super mario brothers was to
platforming games it was
groundbreaking it invented z targeting
it gave us the song of storms and gerudo
valley most awkward of time critics
these days call its gameplay old and
outdated and not very fun to play and
they have a point that is true but i
will say this i hopped on and tried it
out the other day when the nintendo 64
emulator went live on the switch online
service expansion pack thing and it felt
kind of laggy just like it did back in
the old nintendo 64 days which of course
is a little concerning for an emulator
but guess what i still kicked ass i just
kind of zoned back in to how i used to
play it back on the original console
that's sitting right there on my table i
think the issue is if we're big enough
to admit it not that the gameplay itself
is just too difficult to get into but
that modern gamers just don't really
want to take the time to get good at it
but like i said everyone's opinion is
valid and nobody has to try something
that they don't want to anyway the final
game on this list as you already know is
breath of the wild a game that once
again shattered expectations and blew up
in popularity as a result i mean it's
not even a competition ocarina of time
with its several releases comes in just
shy of 14 million units sold while
breath of the wild surpasses 26 with
just two versions and it deserves it
it's got plenty of puzzles plenty of
unique gadgets and probably way too much
free space to explore but it's not the
perfect zelda game in my opinion see i
have this ancient video out on my
channel that you totally don't have to
check out but you totally can if you
want to where i talk about my feelings
regarding breath of the wild right after
i played it some nearly five years ago
and the tl dr was that i was somewhat
disappointed it was mostly because of
the style of storytelling though and to
be honest in recent years now that i've
played it several times over i've
developed much more appreciation for its
story but for those who go into it
expecting the same feeling that they got
from previous zelda games that might
have been their favorite they might end
up being a bit disappointed after you
get past all the fancy open world and
sandbox physics which are hardly unique
to zelda i won't take the time to
full-on review it in this little section
on this video but i will summarize my
thoughts with this simple sentence
breath of the wild is a phenomenal open
world game and an okay zelda game
triple s tier and there you have it my
official mass nintendo bandit zelda tier
list that i made as a final celebration
of zelda 35. you'll notice that i didn't
include a few games from the series and
that's because those are the games that
i haven't played at all and therefore
have no personal opinion on so i will
leave these games up to you my viewers
who might have played them let me know
in the comments below where you would
put these games on my list i look
forward to reading your comments
after i go live with the video also
thank you so much for watching this
video and all the other ones that i made
in 2021 this year just flew by i think
for everyone especially after the
craziness that was last year and i'm so
grateful to every one of you for being
here and again growing the channel
farther than i ever thought possible i
still have just like 10 000 subscribers
in my head like i still cannot fully
comprehend just how big mass nintendo
bandit is at this point but i hope each
and every one of you knows exactly how
much you mean to me and i hope that i
can continue to entertain you in 2022
onward
which hopefully is going to be the year
where breath of the wild 2 releases to
the public finally fingers crossed
anyway that's all i've got for this one
and that's all i've got for this year
leave a like if you enjoyed the video
and subscribe so that i see you next
year this is mastintinabandit looking
forward to the future with you and
signing out on 2021
peace
you